right so just over two years ago I made
a video where I did a C plus plus
University assignment I'll have the
video linked up here it was quite an
interesting assignment but you guys seem
to really dig that video and so I
thought the time had come for me to do
it again so I thought to myself the year
is now 2023. how do people do
assignments these days if I was in
university these days how would I do an
assignment and then I thought well
earlier this year I made a video where I
used AI
The Talk of the Town to help me with
stay plus and that was pretty cool again
video linked up there it had given me
some really great suggestions and it was
even able to adapt to different kind of
code Styles or whatever really that I
asked of it and that was just like gbt3
like people in the comments were being
like no no this isn't the most advanced
AI model you can use this is Child's
Play oh and so here we are today today
we are going to do a C plus plus
University assignment with the help of
AI and I'm gonna use my experience as a
superclass programmer to see how good of
a job it does and this time going into
it I am fairly confident that it's
probably going to do a very good job
where do I get a C plus plus University
assignment from I thought about this for
a while in fact I even asked you guys to
send some in but then they were all
pretty trash but then then I realized
where in the world of AI
why don't we just get AI to write us a C
plus plus assignment and so that's
exactly what I did now what it generated
was probably the most
uninspired boring assignment I've ever
seen honestly so I asked it to I don't
know just change it up a little bit and
so here we have C plus plus University
assignment Cat Cafe management system
now this is basically the same
assignment as it generated the first
time round I mean the objectives are
completely the same they're identical
it's just kind of reskinned right it's
just dressed up a little bit different
instead of like a banking system it's
just it's cats which is like cool I
approve of that in fact I've been to a
cat cafe once I remember in Japan on my
honeymoon so relatable so our assignment
here is to design a system to manage a
cat cafe where visitors come to enjoy a
cup of coffee and spend time with
resident cats the system should help the
cafe manage their cats monitor the
available cat treats and log visits by
customers amazing I mean I'm I'm I'm
hooked I'm invested in this let's build
a cat cafe management system and then
maybe later we can find some cat cafes
to sell it to so let's kind of read
through this assignment and then and
we're gonna just begin working on it and
I haven't quite figured out exactly how
I want to play this like because I'm
thinking I mean I haven't read this yet
but I'm thinking I could obviously just
be like hey
um give me the solution to this
assignment like just write it for me
give me an example of an implementation
of this
but I don't know if that's necessarily
Fair because I mean in this case
obviously it was gbt4 that actually gave
us this assignment in the first place if
we got one from University then I mean I
suppose we could enter all of it into
gbt4 so that it has like the full
context I don't know I think it just
might be better for us to pretend that
we're a student start working on this
thing and then we'll just ask for help
as we need it and in fact I might even
open up a new kind of chat session to
ask for help just so that hopefully it
doesn't have this context because
otherwise that's going to make prompting
it a lot easier I want it to kind of be
not aware of the full requirements so
that it forces us to phrase our
questions probably in a better way and
again like this is gpt4 so I expect that
it's like quite Advanced it's going to
be able to kind of help us out now
speaking of advanced AI systems that can
help you out let's talk about grammarly
the sponsor of this video grammarly
helps professionals improve their
writing all the way from start to finish
so they can quickly deliver high quality
work with confidence so I'm a man of
many jobs there's a lot of things that
I'm doing you guys know that I'm a
YouTuber making videos such as this one
I'm also running a team making a game
engine which that in and of itself
involves so many different disciplines I
would call it I'm not just a technical
director software engineer writing the
actual engine and all the programming
that goes along with that I'm also
running the team which means that I'm
regularly talking to the team whether
that be just on Discord or by email I'm
setting up meetings and creating
presentations I'm writing technical
documentation and just documentation in
general for the engine I'm exchanging
business emails with our partners I mean
the list just goes on and all of those
tasks involve writing now see this is
where grammarly comes in grammarly is an
AI powered writing tool it helps with
all of the things I've just described
like for example if I'm going through
Hazel's documentation and I realize that
actually I need some more ideas for
example games that I can create I can
just ask grammarly hey can you please
generate some ideas for me and in fact
while I'm at it I'm reviewing this kind
of section I don't know if I like the
way that this is written maybe this
needs to be rephrased somehow I don't
know maybe let's try making it sound a
bit more academic and serious although I
don't want to sound too serious maybe
let's just make it sound a little bit
nicer friendlier a bit more fun ah there
we go I kind of like that a lot more
emails I honestly struggle a little bit
sometimes with emails because I don't
want to kind of say the wrong thing
sound unprofessional or just you know
come off a certain way if what I'm
talking about involves Like A Serious
Business Partnership that maybe hasn't
quite been established yet or if I'm
just replying to Peter and I can't be
bothered I can just get Graham later
quickly suggest a reply for me based on
the context of the actual email which is
amazing now grammarly is actually free
to use and try out you can sign up and
download it for free by just going to
grammarly.com Cherno link will be in the
description below if you go on to like
it and you want to get access to extra
features then my link will get you 20
off premium huge thank you to grammarly
for sponsoring this video so step one
over here is obviously going to be to
read the assignment and I'm kind of
gonna critique it I'm gonna just like
see I guess what I'm just gonna give my
thoughts on what what exactly has been
generated here so we know what the
problem description is let's look at the
requirements class cat private data
members blah blah and our objective is
to familiarize students with the concept
of classes objects member functions
inheritance and basic and put out
foreign okay and then we've got a class
called cat with private data members
public member functions so this is
obviously like a very object oriented
kind of C plus plus thing and in fact
the first assignment it gave us was
exactly the same like it was also here
we have a class called account instead
of cat and again the concepts of classes
objects member functions all that kind
of stuff now this doesn't actually have
inheritance I'm just noticing now this
apparently has included inheritance and
then it's telling us like in detail how
to actually structure these classes it's
not just saying yeah just make this
system that fulfills like he has a list
of requirements it has to fulfill it's
actually full on giving us like the
architecture of this program so I want
to mention a couple things here because
I know there's going to be some haters
out there who are already going to be
dissing this because it's object
oriented this is a first year C plus
plus University assignment I
specifically wrote first year so we're
going to kind of use that as the context
here if I think back to my first year I
just feel like C plus plus these days
especially is introduced as an object
oriented a programming language like
it's not immediately introduced as like
a well you know it supports multiple
programming paradigms it could do
object-oriented programming or you could
do something else like you know is
object aren't to the best choice for
like a lot of cases well it might be for
some things but like ultimately maybe
you want to consider no this is a first
year student you have to picture this
person doing this assignment as someone
who's potentially never written code in
their lives up until now I mean I don't
know if this is going to be a first
assignment of ever but a first year
assignment so this person is clearly
very new to programming potentially
never written code before they took this
University course which means what which
means they don't even know what
object-oriented programming is so
obviously it doesn't make sense to kind
of get in here and be like oh this is so
object oriented man like what are you
doing Getters and Setters and there's
like inheritance and objects and classes
like why well because the person needs
to know what object-oriented programming
is before they can then go on to hate it
potentially so clearly that just needs
to be said I think now as to the fact
that this entire architecture is kind of
given to us well yeah because this
assignment is kind of here to teach our
first year student how they would even
go about doing something like this so I
think the fact that this is so quite
this is quite explicit and it's giving
you like exactly what you need to do you
know there has to be a function called
consume trait with this parameter which
reduces the quantity I think that's fair
I think that's a good thing and I think
that that's probably pretty indicative
if my memory serves me well of what it
was like when I did my first year
actually my first year program was
exactly 10 years ago 2013 was my first
year in University and I kind of taught
myself programming a couple years
started a couple years before that when
I was still in high school but I do
remember that C plus plus to us was
introduced as like an object-oriented
programming language just like C sharp
and Java which was also taught and
because the first semester was actually
C and Pascal but mostly C when we went
into C plus the next semester it was
kind of introduced to us as C but with
classes and objects so I got a
Constructor to initialize data members
function display CAD details to display
the cast name okay set her and get a
functions for each data number sure and
see this is what I mean like does the
student even know what a Saturn a getter
is they were probably taught that in a
lecture before they were given this
assignment and now they have to practice
implementing Etc and get a possibly for
the first time ever so because of that
so far so good class treat private data
members we've got two here construction
utilized data members consume trade
display trade details to display trade
name and quantity and again Saturn
Getters customer visit because we have
to also log when a customers visit we
got their name storing some personal
details here every time you walk into a
cafe they write down your name and which
cat you interacted with string okay so
assume interaction with only one cat
perverse I'm almost picturing a database
here with like you know like primary
keys and like foreign keys and how they
relate and like a relational model for a
database here but it's just as simple as
we just got a string of what the cat's
name I guess is because cats do in fact
have names and then we got a day to
visit in the format day day month month
year year okay cool some public
functions and then we go down to the
main program flow so see this isn't
really given in so much detail it lays
out the kind of data model I guess and
the structure of all of these classes
but we don't know exactly how to add a
new cat for example that's just
something we have to do we have to
present the user with a menu to choose
an action and then we can choose to
either add a new cat display all cats
add traits consume traits okay consume
traits so I guess we can get a cat to
eat a treat by logging it in like this
log a customer visit display all visits
and exit so for each action prompt the
user for the required details for
instance when adding a new cat also cast
name but okay right so we just we say we
want to add a new cat and then it asks
us one by one ish kind of data thing
just like making a new user like in the
Linux command line I guess keep the
program running until the user choose to
exit Okay so we've got kind of like a
standard while loop console running
application with prompts we have to read
in the kind of console input for
Simplicity you don't need to implement
persistent storage okay right so once
the program is closed all data will be
lost so I guess it said all right basic
input output and C Bus Plus so not like
file input output that's kind of what I
was picturing but just I guess console
input and output so that's good it kind
of reduces the workload here we don't
need to serialize this like to a text
file so we definitely won't do that
assume that cat names are unique yes
which makes sense because we need to
store this
um and also one cap per visit cool you
can only Touch One Cat every time you go
to the cafe three quantities should
never go negative fair enough we could
probably just use an unsigned integer
for that although do we have to stick to
the trade quantity being an ant because
it didn't say unsigned int so maybe we
do so okay maybe we will and we'll just
kind of have a little check to make sure
that if we don't have any treats to give
we don't subtract a tree extra challenge
I don't know if we'll do the extra
challenge so if I'm going to drive class
special oh right yeah because I was just
about to say there's no inheritance here
it doesn't look like there is but I
guess in this in the extra challenge
there is um additional data like special
skill can open doors fetches like a dog
cool Implement function display all
visits where a specific cat was was
interacted with and implemented a trait
recommendation function system should
suggest the cat's favorite trade and
check its availability did the cat have
cats do have a favorite treat okay cool
right so that would that's why that
would come into play I guess submission
guidelines submit a single CPP file
containing the implemented Cat Cafe
management system include appropriate
comments to explain your code and ensure
the code is free of errors and can pass
successfully of course and then the
evaluation criteria will be correctness
of code proper use of classes blah blah
post readability and organization and
handling edge cases and providing
appropriate user feedback perfect code
to you with a cat emoji and a coffee
beautiful it doesn't say anything about
like you have to use this compiler
because last time we had to use GCC uh
so I'm just going to use visual studio
and msvc for this assignment we do need
a single CPP file yeah I mean overall
like this is actually pretty cool I
think that if you like wanted to
practice something maybe that you're not
good at in C plus like maybe you're not
very comfortable with file i o and you
just want it to kind of generate an
assignment that you could then do like
of course you could just find example
ones online or you could use something
like a lead code to practice things but
I really think the benefit here is just
being able to craft a specific thing
that you want rather than trying to have
to go looking for it and then
potentially wasting time and not finding
it or finding something that doesn't
quite match your requirements so this is
kind of cool like I could really see
this being useful or something that just
creates exercises and assignments for
people to practice certain things so I'm
pretty happy with this now as for how I
want to do this and how I want to use AI
to help me here I could just ask it and
I want to do a new chat session as I'm
Mansion but I could just ask it to you
know write me a class that's like this
is the cat class and here's you know
with these requirements but the thing is
like I feel like this is so basic the
only real thing you could get wrong here
is probably the syntax if you're not
used to C plus plus and you haven't
quite familiarized yourself and
practiced the syntax like I could see
someone being like Oh how do I write a
class like in in the C plus plus like
you know is that it or there's a compile
error you know because I forgot the
semicolon or something like that and
like how do I do does is it like Java or
whatever or do I have to you know do
that like syntactically there's a lot
you could get wrong if you're a beginner
and I guess you could ask the AI here to
help you out with that and write this
for you but I think I'm gonna try and
pretend that I'm a student who has paid
attention in class and in the lectures
and I know like the basic syntax or at
least I can look at lecture slides to
see like what a class would look like
syntactically and so really what I'm
gonna need help with from the AI is
things like you know present the user
with a menu to choose an action like how
do I do that how do I read in stuff from
the console to the user types you know
maybe I could ask the AI that and it
would be like oh I'll just use the
getline function or use CN or something
like that I think that's how I'm going
to play this just because getting it to
do every single line of code for me is
probably not that realistic to how
people would actually use this I would I
would really hope so let's just
um yeah let's just set up a visual
studio project and we'll get started
okay so here we are in Visual Studio let
me close this I guess I could pretend
that I don't know anything so write me a
C plus plus main function
um and then we can just like copy it so
this prints hello world but sure let's
just grab this and we'll put it in so
we're already kind of generating code
now I'm going to remove some stuff here
I guess I could be kind of forward and
just kind of ask it straight away to
make this whole present the user with a
menu to choose an action thing right
because I think that's what I want to
start from I want to kind of design the
main program flow and then we'll
Implement all these things it doesn't
really matter I guess what order you do
it in but that's just what I'm choosing
so write me a main menu
system in C plus which asks
for a numeric index from console input
I'll just write and then directs me to
an appropriate function
this needs to Loop endlessly until the
user selects the quit option I don't
know what's going to happen let's see
what what happens here certainly I love
how enthusiastic it always is certainly
here's a simple Surplus main function
certainly below the basic implementation
of main menu system
wow okay right I mean this this seems
great okay this is yeah
so it's it's interesting handle invalid
input user enters a letter so seeing
Choice and then choice is an INT see
that's okay so that's really smart that
it's decided to do that because I've
specifically elected to take in an
integer so what if I what if instead of
numbers
I wanted letters to to be my menu
options right so I'm just wondering like
if you'd like to use letters you can
easily modify the code and let's see
what it decides to use here could just
use like a Char yeah it's going to use a
Char okay and it's going to do two upper
even right to make sure that we don't
have any kind of case mismatch and then
it's actually going to even yeah I mean
there's comments here convert to
uppercase to handle both upper and
lowercase input and then there's also
even a summary of the changes made like
again well this is this is great this is
very very useful stuff where was this
one I was learning programming but to be
honest like I don't even know if if I
would use this like I feel like it's not
really cheating but I feel like there's
a special uh not just satisfaction but
you learn a special set of skills when
you have to go out and find this
relevant information yourself instead of
just trying to copy and paste stuff but
of course like from a technology point
of view this stuff is this stuff is
amazing and I could definitely see
myself using this you know when I'm
working on my game engine Hazel and I
you know maybe I have a specific
question about like I don't know Vulcan
sub passes which is like a rendering API
and I'm trying to do some like Advanced
rendering stuff like I could in fact I
have in the past asked it can you
explain these things to me or like
really kind of specific questions about
like but how do I compare this depth
format information with this or whatever
what space are these in like after
certain projections or Matrix
Transformations like for that kind of
stuff like it's really really useful and
I definitely don't feel bad for using it
but you know if you're learning
programming like it really does beg
question should you be using this stuff
or should you kind of be pretending it
doesn't exist I don't know let me know
what you think in the comments below
because I definitely can see the
controversial side to this because in a
way like it definitely could be seen as
cheating now um let's uh I wanna uh the
reason why I asked the letter thing was
I specifically wanted to what if I want
to read in a string rather than a single
chart to make my choice because I really
wanted it to show me how to read a
string okay so it's still going to use
CN with choice but see my problem here
is that if I hit space so see you have
to be kind of uh what if I want to
support spaces in my input you have to
kind of you know play with it a bit and
then there it is so this is what I was
looking for I was looking for it to use
the get line function instead of you
know just CN because what CN is going to
do is like sure you could get it to an
accept an INT or a string or a Char or
whatever and it's cool that it's even
using transform here to kind of convert
the input to lowercase so that it can do
the string compare Harrison's kind of
you know with whatever case you want is
case insensitive but still if you have
spaces there because it's just see in
one item you know a space is like the
delimiter that you would have and that's
gonna kind of break if you if you wanted
to get the whole line so this is it
getting the whole line and then it's
going to obviously be uh you know with
space support here it's going to read in
that entire line so if you are looking
for something specific I guess you you
do have to be specific but we really I
think just want the numeric options
don't we um and the reason why I had to
do this by the way specifically apart
from my own curiosity was because you
know we are going to have to take in
other things like names and breeds and
favorite treats which those things those
strings might have spaces so we
definitely potentially want to be aware
of a system where we could read in an
entire line if we wanted to but for the
menu itself I think we can probably just
use a numeric this doesn't actually say
that your menu it's just as present the
user with a menu to choose an action for
each action prompt these are required
details yeah it doesn't actually say
what we do so I think I still am gonna
just make it numeric here which means
that we can basically come over here to
this first kind of int option over here
right and I'm just going to copy this
code completely just with this button
and we're going to replace our whole
program with that code I'm going to
compile this project just to make sure
this all compiles which I expect it will
of course it's a bit annoying how it's
not I was doing this kind of coding
convention but that's the least of our
concerns Let Me Maybe clean this up a
little bit and there's our kind of main
menu with options so we could just
adjust this it even starts with a new
line which is interesting we'll see how
that plays out welcome to Cat Cafe
um please
choose an option
and then we can just have here option
one two so this is display menu we'll uh
we'll just keep using whatever
convention they use I would write this
like that it's my personal choice but
we'll keep this convention but I think I
will drop this to a new line
I'm sure we could probably tell her that
hey by the way going forward I'd like
opening curly brackets to be on new
lines
um and then this can just yeah I mean
it's even Rewritten it
um and then yeah here it's gonna have it
on a new line so that that's cool we can
just probably you know tell it what our
our design convention is and that's fine
so if we go back here now let's select
um you know all of this stuff so we know
we need these things so let's just copy
this I might just yeah paste it in uh
just add these as comments kind of for
the time being in fact we could even
like copy this I imagine and let's move
it down here I'll just surround this
with words I forgot how to select them
all at the end and then we could just
see out all of them at once like this
and then I guess I should have
technically added new lines here so
let's also do that and semicolons
yeah there's a I forgot the way you can
just select um like if I do this and
then yeah there we go so there I could
just have added them all in one go cool
so now I'll add like a number here that
we can use to just pick the option we
want and
um yeah we could just have kind of enter
your choice as the AI wrote for us and
that's the display menu function
basically done so let's go down here now
um where in the main function we just
get our choice going to display the menu
we're going to handle invalid input over
here which is cool I haven't honestly
seen it handled like this before not
that I spend most of my time doing
console input menus but this is I mean
I'm learning stuff uh and then yeah
invite input please enter a number so
we'll test that out definitely for sure
and then we have the choice that selects
all of them now obviously I would I
could come in here and be like well I
don't really want this to just be
numbers because then I have to switch I
have to kind of switch by number here
that doesn't say much to me maybe I
would prefer this to be like an enum so
that I could actually give a name you
know to all of these menu options but
I'm not going to complicate things here
I'm just going to stick with like what
it's giving me so case one then is in
fact is going to be add a new cat now
I'm not going to make comments I think
for this because we'll just uh we'll
just do add new cart like this and that
will be like one of the kind of function
prototypes for an option here now let's
kind of come up here we'll make add new
cat I might just delete these because
I'm going to rearrange this a little bit
and then here were the implementations I
don't think I'm going to bother I'll
just Define everything up here so that I
don't need those prototypes but it was
nice that it added it for us and then
all this said was you selected option
one or whatever so I'm not literally
losing too much code here so add new cat
and then what do we have let me just
split this view like this so I can just
compare two things at once and then if
we scroll down so we had add new cat
then we had display all cats so at this
point I'm just going to do this I guess
myself so we have uh this was the exit
kind of one so what does that do return
zero so that's just full on access the
program immediately sure we'll stick
with that why not and then yeah we can
we can do goodbye as well uh default
we'll just do invalid Choice as well
which is fine so display all cats three
four five six and we'll just update
these quickly so you you can see I am
doing some programming myself like I'm
deliberately trying to be realistic here
and not just get it to do everything for
me because I just don't imagine anyone
would at least anyone actually trying to
learn programming with this and just
using AI to help which is kind of the
point you know I'm using AI to help me
not do the assignment fully for me maybe
that could be another video actually if
I try and actually not write any code
myself but when I'm gonna do that today
so log customer visit and display all
visits now I have to make all these
functions uh let me see if I can do that
a bit
easier
by maybe doing something like this
so void void
and then if I just do this so what was
it I did that and then I went back and
then I can just do that okay so it's
almost perfect so here are all my
functions they're all called from here I
mean we can run this already and we can
just make sure that you know the exit
thing works so I mean if I just do two
it's just gonna yep it's gonna loop
again which is great I can keep pressing
this if I do eight it will tell me that
it's an invalid choice if I type in
Cherno it's going to tell me that's an
invalid input please enter a number
um if I do like six what if I do six and
four
so
that will
yeah see that kind of you can see that
kind of that kind of did it twice so
maybe that's a bit of a bug uh it
doesn't really tell us we have to handle
you know input like that though maybe we
could just say that well it wasn't in
the assignment requirements but I guess
we could get it to make sure that it
only accepts one number rather than you
know takes in multiple things here but
if we do seven then you can see it does
in fact stop the program and it closes
so that's pretty good like we got
something working really quickly I think
if I wasn't explaining this and we did
actually Implement like all seven
options as well which took a bit of time
just to format that code so now I I
think we can just begin with
implementing like this cat class as an
example so we know we need these fun
okay I'm just going to copy this I guess
just so that I can see it over here
we're going to come up here to the very
top we're going to paste this in and
then we're just going to write class cat
we're gonna put our public stuff first
and then our private stuff at the bottom
and then we're gonna have a city string
name I'm going to use this convention
for that we'll have to include string
which you know again I'm assuming that
this person who's doing the assignment
knows a little bit about like you have
to include string two string and what in
fact is a string in C plus plus that
kind of stuff we've got the breed we've
got the age which is an integer which we
will also initialize to zero and then we
got a favorite tree favorite tree um
okay and then we've got a Constructor
okay so a Constructor to initialize data
members so I'm guessing this maybe wants
us to actually take in these members
with this like I mean I would probably
pass this by either a cons reference or
taking a string view or something like
that I don't know if this person I guess
I'll keep it simple like it's not going
to really do any harm if we copy that
string so I'm going to just do it you
know like I would if I was a beginning
programmer probably so we've got name
breed age and favorite treat over here
and then we're gonna use we're just
gonna assign it like that I guess I
could do M name equals name to be a bit
more beginner maybe but we'll just do
we'll go we'll go with this I'm gonna
say the person doing this assignment
knows a little bit he's been around the
block a few times he knows some things
or maybe he was taught this immediately
in a lecture which would be great so
we've got a display cat details to
display the cat's name age and favorite
treat uh well yeah all the all the stuff
so cat details I'll say you know and
then maybe we'll do space space name
name
I don't know like am I being a little
bit too like am I doing too much of this
assignment myself like I don't know it's
kind of hard to tell I should do I'll do
M line instead of new line here
um I don't know like again I'm really
just trying to get help with this like
this does not this does not like require
help I think this is just simple
printing of values like you really
should know how to do this so I'm gonna
just say that like again I I foresee
that the biggest problem that students
are going to have with this part of the
assignment is probably syntax like
forgetting like oh how do I do this
weird stuff instead of just doing Eminem
Michael's name uh not knowing you know
how to maybe write a class in the first
place and like how to make fitsoft
public and private and I'm guessing like
you could probably I don't know like if
I forget a semicolon here and this
doesn't compile maybe I could be like
hey what's wrong syntactically with this
code and I'll paste that in is
synthetically correct as a class
definition how there are a few things
you might not might be aware of
necessary head is okay after your class
definition a semicolon is required you
already have it so that's correct
no I don't yeah I don't know that's a
little bit weird
um that it says you already have it huh
that's very strange there's no main
function here obviously uh and then it's
there's even a way to test this out
which is kind of cool it's got the
function call so that's giving me some
help with syntax as well and this looks
correct so yeah you can definitely ask
it for help with syntax if you kind of
run into that so that's good to know and
to be honest like I don't think I would
consider that cheating
um I think that's okay if you use it for
help with that if you get it to write
your whole program it's different story
and in fact even what I'm doing here by
getting it to write a menu system for me
is probably a gray area Okay cool so the
last thing is is Saturn getter functions
for everything so let's go ahead and
again I'm not going to return by const
reference here I'm just going to do
string get name uh do I put cons here
would it be gonna do that would they be
taught that maybe I'm going to keep it
simple return M name uh let's duplicate
that a few times we got breed age which
is an INT and favorite treats all right
cool so we've got some Getters uh we
need some Setters as well okay cool
um I think that's it so that's the
complete implementation of the cat class
I think that's basically all it was
asking for now in the interest of
keeping this video not the length of a
feature film I'm going to just like fast
forward through me implementing all
these things but I will do them manually
Okay so we've got consume tree which is
a bit different than uh you know what
was in the cat class so if they're not
enough Traces by an error message so
this just really has to just subtract
this but obviously we kind of have to
maybe just be like if M quantity minus
amount is less than zero like zero is
okay if we hit zero exactly we have two
treats and we subtract two we have you
know that's valid you can give two trees
if you have two but if it's less than
zero then we need to not do the
following so I'll do a return here and
then we'll just print an error message
being like not enough
traits I guess we won't give any uh
traits though in that case we're not
going to give all of the ones we have
and then just say there's not enough
we'll just say not enough traits
um we have uh we could even print
something helpful like how many we
actually have uh which of course will be
quantity known amount yeah I'll just
leave it at that
okay trade details same kind of story as
cat details
okay and then it gets inside it so that
class is done
okay interesting I just noticed that
this doesn't this doesn't tell us to do
Getters and status for customer visits
so I guess we don't need to do that
that's nice because that takes a while
okay there we go so um that is all three
classes implemented there is quite a lot
of code but of course it's not
particularly complex code or anything I
think this should be definitely
achievable by someone who's trying to do
this assignment so that's why I didn't
really use much of the ai's help on that
so moving on add a new cat what's
interesting immediately to me is this
doesn't actually tell you anything about
the storage it simply says you don't
need to implement position storage but
this doesn't tell you like you know you
have to store all of this stuff in a
vector or in a map or in whatever so
this is interesting already because it's
definitely forcing us to come up with
the idea I imagine you would probably
store like I would probably store the
cats as some sort of like you know that
they need to be unique so you could just
store it as a set honestly so you would
have like you know an instance of the
cat class and you would use the name of
the cat as like the key for it to be
inside a set but you are still storing
the actual you know object that might be
a little Advanced for this it might just
make more sense to just store it as a
vector and then you know obviously you
would you would then iterate throw it to
display all cats add traits so obviously
traits are in a vector and consumer
trades as well
um the traits have names I I'm assuming
they need to be unique as well uh you
know so I'm beginning to find holes in
this assignment in terms of like what
details are given and whether or not all
the edge cases are kind of you know
handled lower customer visits so again
you could do that and display all visits
in a vector so to keep this simple I
think I'm just going to use a vector for
these things so let's go back to our our
actual prompt over here and let's be
like let's kind of ask for help so I
have a cat class which has you know name
breed uh age and favorite treat which
has strings name breed and favorite
treat and an ant age I need to prompt
the user through a console to enter all
of these details and then add this to
and STD Vector for storage
I also need to iterate through this
Vector to print all the cats that I have
right two functions that achieve these
two tasks so let's see what happens here
I'm interested to see
so okay so it's actually written this
NBF and a in that order as well uh we
can print that as well okay right so
it's gonna I guess it's gonna call this
function rather than doing the printing
from with that makes sense from within
the thing so add cat SCD Vector cats
taking them in by reference okay so it's
not it's not yeah it's not using any
Global variables or anything that kind
of makes sense I think to me uh yeah get
line for all of these things from CN
again using get line here so it is
opening this up to have spaces which is
great then we've got cat new cat and
then a pushback sure so it's not using
like in place back or trying to do
anything fancy here with move semantics
like it's really just making this and
pushing it back causing a copy totally
fine again for this assignment don't
care just pointing that out so print all
casts will go through again that vector
and it even adds some nice pretty uh you
know things here cat.print is what it
calls and then I've got my cat
collection I like the recorded cat
collection
um and then I can do chart Choice even
which lets me add a cat which calls that
so this I didn't ask for it's got some
example usage though yeah so it's it
provides you with example usage I think
is really cool definitely and then it
just prints this and while the choice is
that or that then we can keep adding
cats until we're satisfied so that's
yeah that's really cool let's go ahead
and do this so again I'm just going to
copy this my cat collection I'm gonna
put it in my main function just like
that you know thing did it I'm going to
keep calling it cat collection now cat
is a thing uh Vector is not I'm going to
add that in I'm going to pretend that I
know that part but of course you could
be like why is STD Vector giving me a
compiler or like in fact let's just try
that I'm again this is almost silly to
try giving me a compile error
um you know it probably is just going to
tell me have you included it right uh
Missing include directive right so
include Vector yeah so that's that's
done don't even need to worry about that
we've got my cat collection now going
back up here and this is obviously this
is the other chat so this has no context
I'm assuming that's how gbt4 works it
doesn't have any contacts uh so I
shouldn't know about the cat class which
it clearly doesn't because it's
completely different then I'm just going
to grab this add card function as is
right and then just Chuck that in add
cat we've got our Vector of cats we've
got all these different things I'm just
going to rearrange this slightly though
so that we do the age uh here what about
error checking though this doesn't
really have any error checking um you
know if I don't add you know what if the
age is a string or something so I could
you know use this to re-prompt it while
that's an issue could just be out of the
scope for this assignment though not
sure and then to make this so name so we
need string spring string and which is
it's the other way around obviously so
let's just assume we can fix that
ourselves that is so there we go so now
add a cat add new cat let's just call it
add new cat and then we can get rid of
this one it's an overload though because
it's a different signature it's got
different parameters but either way
we'll do add new cat and then we'll just
do cat collection we'll just pass that
in and yeah we should just be able to
add new cats now I'm assuming we'll test
it in a minute print all cats uh let's
just grab the well we need this as well
I'll grab this part of it because we've
already got that function remember so
display all cards so let's just paste it
in here like that print print so it's
called not print it's called display cat
details so let's go ahead and I love
this is involving cats by the way I'm
but I decided to ask her to do that
rather than Banks
um so we'll do cat display cat details
okay we have our first issue that might
not be easy to solve this is giving me
an error the reason why is because I was
being a naive C plus plus programmer and
I was not marking this as const so this
function is not marked as const which
means that if this guy over here
um inside display all cats which let's
pass in cat collection this guy is a
const cat right not just a regular cat
this guy's a const cat this cat's a
const cat so that means that it only the
const functions can be called yeah I
mean let's see what it says so the
object has Type qualifies and
uncompatible ah you I guess you could
enter this into like gbt and be like
what's up but this is definitely an
issue uh this is definitely an issue now
if we look at this though see this
doesn't have Getters at all and the
print oh hang on though
check this out the print function here
is not const
so actually this is a compile error in
the car that is generated because look
it's a const cat we do cat dot print on
that cat object which is const and yet
print is not const
so there we go gpt4 just gave us code
that does not compile
there you go the world's crumbling
um right well good
you know this is a help me uh Professor
hi I'm not as smart as I thought I was
and gpt4 didn't bail me out so are you
sure that code example with the cats
compiles let's see what it says to that
I apologize for the oversight let me
quickly review the card here's a revised
version hey
that's so interesting
what did it just not think about it
okay so okay so if I get a compile error
here as a student I might be you know
smart enough or just say to plug in this
as a stat because this is a standalone
Pro program with a main function I might
I might think to just plug this in into
a standalone application and then see
that like well it doesn't compile right
so like as an example here I'm in
wandbox I'm just going to paste this
this is one box though it's just a
little online compiler if I compile this
it will tell me that cons count as this
argument discards qualifies because this
obviously is not cons so I might
actually this is straight from the code
and I might be like well you know what's
wrong with this and so I might ask it
you know are you sure that compiles just
like I did right it gives me a revised
version I can paste that in run it see
that this in fact does work right and
then I could find the difference but
also it tells me that the print function
in cat is now a const member function
since it doesn't modify class member
also while adding a cat to the vector I
utilize in place back for direct
construct action beautiful is an
improvement by using pushback with a
temporary cat object is fine too okay
um I I'm not going to argue with it that
it's fine too of course it depends on
the use case and for this case it's
definitely fine but obviously in place
back is optimal and it has in fact you
can see it's done that with the
construction so I might be like oh
that's fancy let's try and like replace
that and then obviously instead of
constructing this object here it's
passing along the arguments and then
constructing it in place inside the
vector which is technically better so
then I would come up here and be like oh
you know this turns out this needs to be
const um I've learned something you know
so that's kind of cool uh not cool that
it made a mistake though I honestly
didn't expect it to make a mistake like
in a mistake in terms of like this is
basically a syntax there is only a
syntax error but it's an error in it's a
grammatical we'll say error maybe in C
plus bosses like system is it just like
it's it's type error really like it's
not going to compile at all like that I
did not expect but uh we now have the
ability to just like cats let's run this
uh okay we've got an arrow here what's
the error
um oh okay so for some reason name breed
are because age needs to be here yep
again like we'll just sweep that one
under the rug uh okay so add a new cat
and a cat's name and a cat's breed or
why is that immediately ask me two
things
that's weird
get line should have waited
is that something to do with this
cat's age 50 that's an old cat uh
uh chocolate
that's weird why did it do this
okay so display all cats and then we've
got
no name breed is weird uh 50 and
chocolate all right all right isn't that
strange
that's I don't even know what to say
about that I don't even know why that
happened me as like as a programmer not
as chat gbt looking at this I don't know
why that happened is it because this
didn't consume ah we'll see this is
doing CN choice
this might be problematic
because if this is doing CN Choice then
it it's not gonna consume new lines
potentially and so
this might consume that new line I guess
because it's it's waiting in the buffer
to be consumed that's what I imagine has
happened
um is there a way to clear it I don't
know so this is again something I guess
I would ask it so let's see uh it's
prompting me for both the name and breed
in one go can I why that's interesting
behavior of sin combined with get line
there you go yep when you enter data for
the choice in the main function using CN
Choice which is what we did so this
doesn't know I've done that though
because this is different right uh to
read the cast name it immediately A
Reason consumes the leftover new line
character and it appears just skipping
the prompt so that's exactly what I
thought would happen but great that it
explained it that's amazing like this is
great the solution is to see and ignore
right after reading the choice which
will consume the leftover new line
character however in the provider code I
already have ignore after reading
stories so it should be working fine in
that regard
um yes uh oh that's the example oh so
that's lucky because it used CN for the
example I see why because I was like how
do you know that I'm combining CN with
getline but it's because you know get
line is used here and scenes used in
their example as well as there but then
you can see it you can all see it so the
solution then from there I would imagine
is you know again I'd have to deduce
this I guess but you'd have to base
basically be like after this
um you know maybe we should just ignore
this right would that be correct again
I'm not a full-on console programmer
here add a new cat well there you go and
then we get the cat's name
um so I have a cat called the leafka
which means Olive in Russian cats breed
I don't know man uh I actually don't
know cap rates so what uh give me a list
of cat breeds I don't know how long this
list is gonna be but we can just do that
all right
let's go with
um that's a lot man stop
damn that's this is a lot I did not know
there were so many cat breeds there are
many other breeds well yeah I mean I
imagine there's a lot but okay let's go
with um let's go with uh Maine I
think I know this is like the huge one
right oh I have no idea what cat I have
though by the way it's just a simple
card um but we can you know we can be
like Maine we can make this up as
well cats age um I think I live because
like three
Cass favorite treats oh I don't know I
don't really give a traits that much
I'm a bad cat or not I'll just write
like tuna or something okay cool so
display all cats and then here we go
let's add another cat this will be a
fictional cat uh the breed is classified
uh the age is 80. this is like an alien
cat here and the favorite treat is
anything all right so now we've got two
cats we got alifka and we got our
fictional classified cat okay great so
that's that's working add treats again I
assume you would just copy this like
literally copy everything so we could
have treat we could have our treat
collection while we're at it we know
that we're also going to need customer
visits so uh I'm just I'm gonna I'll
just call it customer visits because
it's getting long so we've got add
treats which I'm gonna go down here
we'll probably put this in order but uh
yeah like I mean I'd honestly probably
just copy this entire thing add treats
then this would be obviously treat
treats instead uh whatever trait has
which is just trade name and quantity is
what I would put in here so treat name
I'll stick to naming these things
properly and then yeah quantity is going
to be this uh we'll get rid of this but
we'll keep that so there's gonna be a
treat name enter trait name and then
quantity with the ignore here which is
cool good because there's a comment
there traits in place back and we'll go
with Tree name obviously and quantity
and we need to also adjust this
um you know cats age thing which we'll
just do
enter trade quantity that's done consume
traits so that if we go back here that
needs to consume treats that's back here
right consume treats so consume tree
which that's just something we can do I
guess we need to specify what cap we
want to consume the trade right oh and
also who's doing it see this is like
it's falling apart a little bit here
because it's like you know log a
customer visit but logging a customer
visit involves just CAD interacted with
oh but I guess it doesn't it doesn't
want an advanced system right where it's
like you know when we do consume tree we
also need to specify which customer gave
the cat which trade and doing so results
in a cat interacted with situation I
don't think that's like this I think
this is just so you just log all these
things so it's a little bit uninspired
and boring in that sense I think there
definitely could have been a bit more
interaction in this assignment like I
would have definitely done a system
where like you know you log an
interaction and that means that the
customer is kind of giving the cat a
treat and you kind of log that instead
of just having to be like oh yeah by the
way this customer interacted with this
because there's no like relation between
these things they're basically just
discrete things where you have a cat
with a collection you have a trait and a
collection of traits and then you have a
customer visit
um and that's just a collection of data
and they don't really ever uh you know
cross they don't have any kind of
situation right where well I guess apart
from this though where the customer is
linked with a cat so then you could
produce different things like hey what's
the most popular cat
um you know and then you could ask it
based on how many customers have
interacted with that cat but otherwise
it's kind of boring in that sense anyway
I guess we'll just finish the assignment
it's probably going to be boring I don't
know if it's going to make for good
content because it sounds like I think
the majority of it's kind of done right
but I might as well finish it uh so
let's do consume trades which is
basically we just need to specify like
that a treat was consumed so to consume
a treat I guess you would need to take
in the again should I should I get the
AI to do this for me probably not but I
can say find an element inside side of
vector by name elements are classes
which contain a name String so this is
like if I need to find something I'm not
sure how to do that if you have a class
with a name String member and you want
to find it then okay interesting so it's
telling me to use find if which is kind
of cool well returning a pointer all
right it's getting a bit different than
what I had the way I would have done it
so find Cap by name okay it's using my
my cat thing fluffy that's a great name
whiskers fluffy and mittens cute so
found cat and then sure and then if
found cat call so if the if the point is
valid otherwise well not valid but the
point is not zero then that otherwise
that and yeah like I'm in and find if
with a Lambda
I mean I probably would I wouldn't do it
this way obviously like okay I'll show
I'll show ah am I trying to get AI to do
this though now I'm now I'm conflicted
now I'm not sure what I should do
because like obviously I would just
iterate through traits right I would
just take in this consume traits so we
could have out all of our treats and
then treat name to consume basically and
then we could also take in uh oh
actually no we would prompt the user for
this stuff right so you'd basically do
this exact same thing and to treat name
and quantity to consume let's add this
so it's a bit more we have more context
and then we could use the find F here
uh should we do that though because then
iterator doesn't equal end like that's a
bit annoying I would imagine that you
would just write a for Loop can you do
this using a for Loop so maybe I don't
know what this weird Lambda syntax
syntax is I know what for Loops I've
been taught that let's see absolutely
you can use traditional lockout that's
traditional uh for lift it arrow through
Vector so let's see the solution it
gives us here yeah just going through
carts doing a comparison and then in
this case cons casting oh
ouch okay that's I don't know how I feel
about this card but let's copy it
um then this is yeah this is very
interesting
um I can kind of see it falling apart
here a little bit but it's cool like
because I've never gone ahead and done
this so let's kind of search for it here
uh in terms of traits it's a trait not a
cat here we've got the get name I think
right get I think it's called get treat
name though is that right oh did I I use
my big convention here without even
realizing it big convention that's funny
get treat name name to find is going to
be this trait name you know there's no
transformation here to a lower case
which is okay I guess uh this again is
not const so but I've learned that from
before I hope so I'm just going to add
cons to here because obviously I had to
do it for the display cat details and
then like I'm not trying to return it
I'm just trying to see that if well if I
did find it then I need to consume it so
I'll just do treat dot uh isn't there a
consume treat yeah consume treat which
again needs to be const here or I just
don't through here which I'd need to
know as well so I definitely need to go
back and forth a bit more I think and
then what are we doing are quantity
right which surely was given and then I
can just return because I've done it
I've done my job I've consumed my trait
um what was this a consumerator is just
an amount I've made it not cost anymore
but I believe like because if this is
const then I might have to remove cons
from here this is all just falling apart
a little bit but I I guess I kind of
have to do that if I do in fact I want
to modify it or I could use const cost
which is not advised okay so I've
consumed my trade otherwise I could
print something like there is no trade
by that name and then you know you could
just try again or like I guess you could
enter the menu option again so that's
that um we obviously need a way to
actually add the treats though right so
do we have a way to do that there's ad
trades consume trades so let's do treat
collection here you know add traits
again same kind of story I'm just gonna
copy basically the ad
where's the ad add new cat
add new cat function let's copy that
let's go to the add treats function oh
we already did that
I didn't even realize what how did I I
just zoned out that's funny um so add
treats we've got log customer visit and
display or visit so we'll do the final
piece of the puzzle here I've got that
um you know cat copying thing here so
we'll just do uh we'll obviously take in
the customer visit here hopefully
learned enough to do this on my own now
without using too much you know customer
visits without using too much uh AI here
so customer name card interacted with
and data visit these are all strings so
we'll do customer name cat interacted
with and data visit yeah right oh okay
so the day to visit though oh that's
going to be a curveball because that
needs to be in a particular format I'll
have to use AI for that so take
um take uh input from console in format
for a date I don't know let's see what
happens I was kind of just typing
without thinking about how to phrase it
but day month here or okay
um but I want to kind of store it as a
string all right okay
so what's it doing here in validate
components but it's not actually
validating the range is it data massages
in Cortana and then there has to be Dash
Dash and then it's actually storing
these as numbers though okay interesting
uh well actually no that makes sense so
I mean we're part we are parsing it into
an end
even though we have the data input
though but we're kind of doing that just
to make sure that the components
themselves are valid and then I think we
can separate them if we want but we can
just keep them as a string but maybe the
purpose of this is just to make sure
that they are in fact valid integers and
not just letters
so in that sense I could see that this
is actually like you know not bad so
maybe maybe we will use this well yeah
we'll use this why not it's just a
little silly assignment I'm not going to
be all yeah weird about it so with the
date then yeah let's make a little date
section here and then I feel like Visual
Studio is just going crazy here because
I've got compilers so date of visit
we'll just plug that in right and then
we'll do the enter date in the format so
enter we'll do enter visit date in
format that uh we'll get that date input
uh if it's an invalid format um we can
say invalid date format and I guess we
can just return so we won't actually end
up adding anything otherwise we'll pause
it again sure invalidate format I'll do
the same error and then we'll return but
otherwise if the date is correct then we
know we can store it as a correct thing
so in that case we can just proceed and
go into customer visits apologize if I'm
going fast by the way I'm just trying to
get this like you know this is a
dragging on and I think you guys get the
point but just for the sake of
completion you know I want to kind of
make sure that I cover everything
customer name carator with a data visit
so we actually do add the visit if the
day is in the right format otherwise we
don't so that's kind of how I've decided
to handle that and to uh customer name
enter uh cat interacted with
sure
we'll just do that
um and then we'll do so customer name
cat interacted with and then we got the
enter visit date in format and that's
kind of it so that's log customer visit
display all visits again same kind of
story right so we'll do we'll copy this
uh and then we'll do display all visits
this time we'll take in visits this can
be const uh I guess maybe they would
have learned about that
uh customer visit customer visit and
then that has I believe a display visit
details which we can then there's like a
speed run now that we can just kind of
pump in here which again needs to be
const but we've learned that which is
great uh log customer visit so we can
take in customer visits and I believe
we're basically done so let's hit F5
let's see what Mass I've made I'm sure
I've made some mistakes right so uh yeah
let's just try and use this inner
Centauri now so add a new cap so again
we'll go with the leaf car she's not a
Maine but we'll go with that uh
Cafe Retreat
um food
uh display all cats we've got our cat um
add traits so this one's called food we
have five of that let's add another
treat this one's called tuna we have two
of that so let's display the tree we
can't display the traits okay sure but
let's um make the cat consumer tree
maybe so let's go with food let's try
and consume three of that yeah I mean
I'm assuming that worked we didn't
really get any feedback um but if we try
and do let's do uh consume trade again
and we'll do food but let's try and
consume five of it because we should
have lost three
um it'll tell us not enough treats we
have two okay great so I guess we can
try and consume the tuna I'll go with 10
which is yeah we have two we do have two
two tuners then we can let's let's try
and consume the tuna but we'll try and
do two this time yeah that seems to have
worked and if we try so that remains
there though right so if we try and
consume the tuner again even just one it
will tell us we have zero okay cool uh
log a customer visit which is five
customer name is Cherno customers cat
Interactive with a leaf car we don't
validate it that's even a real cat let
me screw up the date here so let's let
me do a a just a a so that's wrong in
validate format fair enough uh like a
customer visit Cherno alifka okay and
now we'll do like I don't know uh what's
the date today 23rd of the 9th of 2023.
uh so that's worked so display all
visits
ah the date's not here why why is the
date not here customer visit date data
visit uh and I am assigning it here so
what's happened here uh log customer
visit date where's my date input I'm
doing data visit because I
uh I had that up here okay so that's
annoying so let's do data visit instead
well actually we can keep date input
I'll remove data visit here and then
we'll make sure the date input is the
thing coming in let's quickly just redo
that last part again we're not
validating if the card even is real
that's not really uh that wasn't asked
of us was it just to make sure that if
you have a visit you visit a cat that's
real
um or rather you interact with a real
cat so let's see if it said that I don't
think it did right it just seems assume
one cap per visit but yeah it doesn't
really say that
okay well again this is like you know
this is just Nova site which this is
filled with so let's quickly just do
that log customer visit again so Cherno
is going to interact with a leaf car
um and we're gonna do the still the same
day and then if I just play all visits
this time I want to get that okay so
that's that's it and then I can
obviously do seven and it just closes so
that's it
um yeah let me know what your thoughts
were in the comment section below I mean
I I started off I this underperformed
compared to what I expected in two major
areas I would say like again overall
obviously this is a very useful tool but
the reason why I didn't quite like it
was because of two things first of all
the compile error generating code with a
compile error
didn't expect that didn't really expect
that but that's what happened and then
the second part is the assignment like
it looked good at first glance but then
when I kept going through it like we
realized that there were in fact holes
in it right so that was a bit
unfortunate I don't know maybe that's
fine to expect that like because of
course it is just you know it's not like
maybe I could have asked it to be like
even more detailed but it didn't give me
the detailed version immediately so it
definitely could have been a little bit
better in the assignment generation but
overall obviously not a bad job now the
final thing I want to do before we end
this is now that we've done this uh
please
I don't know I'm running plays but
please do this
assignment for me let's see I can't
complete assignments for you really
whoa
is this a protection thing but this
isn't this basically it though wow it's
this doesn't want it doesn't want okay
stop generating whatever can you show me
an example implementation of the cat
assignment you gave me let's see if it
certainly here's a cat cafe management
system
huh
so again it's not it doesn't look like a
complete program I mean it kind of
Almost Is I don't know why there's two
of these one things here but a basic
implementation but let's kind of review
this I don't know okay so they see
there's no Getters and Setters even
though it's sad that it had to do that
if quantity greater than equal to amount
minus equals quantity which is fine
that's kind of what we did right so
display tree details obviously did that
it just did it on well I was going to
say I did it on one line it did and it's
got new lines here but they wrote it
across one line then we got the customer
visit thing so customer visit trading
cards so it showed us example
implementations of those three classes
which is great we've got a main function
with menus let's have a look at how it
did it so we got cats treats and visits
yep okay it used vectors just like we
did we've got a choice here of those
seven things it didn't even make a
function for this which is fine we've
got a switch of choice here and then oh
man okay they didn't did not write a
function here and said they kind of
opened these Kelly brackets and wrote
the whole thing here which I probably
wouldn't have done we've got cats pushed
back and it does that instead of in
place back it's almost the same thing
like in terms of the code to type except
yeah okay that's fine though this goes
through and displays cat details
included a little bit of a of a
separator here as well we've got treat
name uh treatment tree quantity same
situation here as well and then yeah
trade name to consume an amount uh it
does yeah of course does this kind of
for Loop here just like we did just like
we wanted to do rather than the STD find
diff uh function with Lambda to find the
right trait then consume it uh it
doesn't tell us anything if it can't
find the trait which is okay get treat
name it's using even though I don't
think that it didn't create that for us
and so instead it wrote a comment being
like assuming that's a member function
but it didn't write it interestingly
okay we've got customer name with this
so yeah does not do any validation on
date like we did so we did that manually
guess the assignment didn't technically
say You must validate data just said it
has to be in that format though but I
guess if it has to be in that format and
you can write anything then it doesn't
have to be in that format so I think the
validation is implied customer visits
like that and again if you do a customer
visit the cad interacted with or not
it's just stored as data it's not
validated at all and then that's kind of
it remember this base complementation
many areas for improvement optimization
code can be extended to handle error
scenarios more gracefully and other
features can be added based on extended
challenges but overall I guess not a bad
implementation definitely some like a
lot of similarities I would say ours was
more complete in terms of like you know
how we actually did implement the
Getters and Setters that had asked for
but otherwise you can see that you can
definitely get it to do the assignment
for you it's interesting that when I
phrased it like uh you know I can't
complete your assignments for you that's
very very interesting but then I just
rephrased it can you show me an example
of implementation of the cat assignment
you gave me it gives me the complete
assignment basically like 90 95 done and
then of course you could just be like I
added add some Getters and says for me
so that's interesting but that's the
ai's implementation this is our
implementation I'm sure no one cares
about this so I don't think I'll post
this code anywhere but it was definitely
an interesting journey I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more AI stuff if you think there's some
AI stuff that I should try in terms of
like programming or C plus plus or
anything let me know in the comment
section below I'm having a lot of fun
honestly just going through and learning
other stuff because I don't do this
outside of videos really to this kind of
extent so it's always a good time always
fun don't forget to check out grammarly
with their amazing Advanced AI stuff
link will be in the description below
and I will see you guys next time
goodbye